DAVID JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome back to recitation.
I'd like to work this problem
with you, in which we're
going to use
determinants to compute
the area of a parallelogram
sitting in a plane.
So why don't you take
a moment to-- why
don't you take some time to work
this out, and we'll check back
and you can see how I did it.
OK, so let's get
started on this problem.
Now the first thing
that we need to be
careful about with
this problem is,
we know that we want
to take a determinant,
but we need to be careful.
Determinants of pairs
of vectors make sense.
Determinants of points
do not make sense.
So here we have
these four points,
which are the endpoints
of the parallelogram.
And what we need to do
from these four points
is get some vectors that
we can compute with.
So over here, I have
taken the vectors
which connect the endpoints
of the parallelogram.
So you'll see that this
[6, 1] here, this vector [6,
1] is coming from the point
(1, 1) in the original
parallelogram and (7, 2).
So this vector [6, 1] is
just the difference of (7, 2)
and the point (1, 1).
And similarly [5, 2]
here is the difference
of our original point (6, 3)
and our base point (1, 1).
So now that we have
these two vectors,
the area of our
parallelogram is just
going to be the determinant
of our two vectors.
Well, we'd better be careful.
It's going to be plus or
minus the determinant,
is going to be the area.
So let's compute
this determinant.
So we find 6 times 2 minus
5-- so we get 12 minus 5 is 7.
Now we got a positive number,
and so this plus or minus
we take to be positive.
Had we computed our determinant
by transposing the rows here,
then we might have
found a negative 7,
and of course we want
our area to be positive,
so we would just choose 7.
So, let me just go through the
one tricky part of this problem
is the original endpoints of
our parallelogram are not what
are important for the area.
What's important is
the vectors which
connect the two of our
endpoints together.
And so we computed those,
[6, 1] and [5, 2], and then
taking their
determinant gives us
the area of the parallelogram.
OK, I'll leave it at that.